[موسيقى]
[موسيقى
] الراهبة في سن المراهقة لا يعلمونك
هذا في المدرسة الآن زوجي نادر
لا يعرف ما يجب فعله سالي ، نحن
نقوى سالي ستمسك ذراعها "  قد يكون
لدينا الكثير من التاريخ ، ويمكننا أن
نكون أعظم فريق شهده العالم على
الإطلاق ،
نعم قد نحصل على الكثير من التاريخ ،
لذا لا تدع الأمر يذهب ، يمكننا أن نجعل
المزيد يمكننا أن نعيشه إلى الأبد
جميعًا  من الشائعات سريعًا بعض الشيء ، لكننا
دائمًا ما نجد طريقة
لإخراجها من السكين الآن كنا
مخطئين الآن سنتوقف الآن ،
أليس من الممكن أن يكون لدينا تاريخ كامل ، أليس من الممكن أن نكون أعظم فريق
لقد شهد العالم من قبل ،
نعم ، قد نحصل على تاريخ
متعلم ناجح ، لذا لا تدع الأمر يذهب ، يمكننا أن نجعل
المزيد يمكننا أن نعيشه إلى الأبد ، لذا لا تتركه ،
لذا لا تدع الأمر يذهب ، يمكننا أن نعيش إلى الأبد
يا حبيبي '  هل تعرف حبيبي ألا تعرف
أنه يمكننا العيش إلى الأبد
[موسيقى]
لن أستخدمها أنا أصرخ yayoi-san
الليلة
[موسيقى]
لذلك نفتقد جميعًا Hester a Veneto judo عندما
مرحبًا ، كان علينا الانضمام إلينا ،
لا ، أنا أروع خطوات العصائر
مع رقص دوني القراصنة إيدي شارلوت
كالاماتا
- مع الحدة الشديدة على كل
شخص ،
تعال إلى
سورة الامتصاص الحاد ، لذا ما
الذي فعلته يا صديقي غير التواصلي يأتي
إلى نيكي دامانيا.  رأيتك لماذا
لا تترك ما هو غريب عن
الحراك هنا ، يتحول العنف إلى
لازانيا كانادا ، ما لا شيء ،
ولن يسرق أونا كاسا إن لاسا اقتصادنا ،
ما سيحدث غدًا ، حسنًا ،
سيكون أبي
هذا هو آني ، هيا يا سيد ،
واو أصفر الخردل الأصفر  الليمون
قاسٍ عليك ،
لقد قلت إنني استمتعت بشدة إلى جانا التي كانت تختبئ
مؤخرًا ثم تعاملت مع Yahoo مثل
الأوتوبوت ،
نعم ، أهلا وسهلا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]